real quick let's go to Aubry from
Wisconsin many said do not speak to
Aubry again on the show but I'm just I
I'm tempted to hear what Aubry has to
say Aubry I don't have a ton of time but
what's on your mind today
wait that is so disrespectful
okay real quick um the first thing you
should have said is like the um Travis
frecker from blank 182 because he
married a Kardashian and Kardashians are
the best anyways
um I wanted to know your opinion on um
that settlement that Fox News came up
with with like
um Dominion do you think they're going
to stop like you know absolutely lying
no is like Tucker Carlson gonna be like
hey I'm still like an Entertainer so
like I could say whatever the shiznit I
want yeah absolutely listen Aubry it's
not only that the settlement between
dominion and fox doesn't even require
Fox to apologize or or say anything on
air in a written statement they said
yeah the stuff we aired wasn't true
they're not even going to take it back
on air and so Tucker is going to keep
doing his thing they'll talk about
Hunter Biden they'll talk about you know
low birth rates with Elon Musk or
whatever else they want it is good it's
not you is Fox going to stop lying now
is a hilarious question no they are not
going to stop lying
okay yeah okay so they're not going to
admit that they were just a clown
that people said don't talk to me
anymore um but I do appreciate it you
are an air sign so I feel like we get
each of those energies but wait I'm a
what what was that I'm an era side so
you're an Aquarius and I'm a Libra
Rising so like we get each other's
energies and that way and I really
appreciate that
um but you're kind of the weird Arrow
sign which like you're kind of like kind
of snooty intellectual which I respect
but like that's fine and this is because
I'm an aquarius you're saying
yeah so essentially you're saying that
the perceived but possibly inaccurate
positions of stars and planets at the
time of my birth determine my
personality
I have time but I will start screaming
about this astrology is absolutely
so I'm a Libra Rising by Massachusetts
which is why people think I'm a Leo
which is like some kind of conceited but
I will assess this because I'm a Libra
Rising only Aries men have ever tried it
really hard with me right like Pisces
dudes I've been with before but they're
like
um Aries men have tried it super hardly
because excuse me I just I just let me
ask I will end on this note okay I want
a yes or no and let me ask the full
question is that okay
okay
is your belief
that the perceived but possibly
inaccurate determination
about the position of stars and planets
at the time of my birth
dictates my personality today yes or no
absolutely all right there you go Aubry
from Wisconsin great to hear from you
bye bye there is Aubry from Wisconsin I
can't think of any better note than that
to end on thank you to everyone who
called in we will take calls again if I
have anything to say about it if they
let me